so the Oscar race is heating up we're
going to talk to the pros about it at
the Super Bowl which is a better
disguise Wade Phillips 3-4 defensive
schemes or any Redmayne and the Danish
girl it's good movie data scripted yeah
oh dear have you ever woken up with a
baby that wasn't yours in Vegas No No
thank God what's going to win best
picture this year revenant yeah do you
feel like that's a metaphor for your
season are you basically the revenant
apply leaving out of the copy I would
lie with a bear's you know I mean by
killed the bear the Martian is a movie
about a guy who is sent to Mars and then
stranded for years who in the NFL do you
want to ditch on Mars none of them the
NFL is a great human being a great
person for some reason you can't make
eye contact with me when you say so I
heard you're sitting out Civil War
what's going on in Thor's world right
now Thor's world yeah I've gotten that a
couple Thompson have you seen the movie
the good dinosaur I hope it's about
Peyton Manning hahaha yeah Kenny they
say that the Super Bowl is the Oscars of
football would you agree with that know
if they made a movie about your career
who would you want to play you I feel
like Owen Wilson would have to play me
yeah why plane for the pants are just
going great so much fun who's prettier
Cate Blanchett or Tom Brady Tom Brady
I've never been attracted Tom Brady I've
seen him nude Batman vs Superman is
coming out soon but who would win Batman
vs super cam oh wow I'm not sure a big
problem probably Batman cuz he's got
gadgets entire Batman and Superman
fighting because it makes money and it's
badass I'm gonna take super cam right
now you were right okay well you're just
saying that cuz he's right here Batman
vs Superman or Batman vs ed hochuli
who's a bigger oscar snub johnny depp
for best actor or Mike Daniels for the
problem
Michael B Jordan or Cameron Jordan
Michael Jordan that wasn't even an
option did you see creep OIC crew get in
the bed that's it from Super Bowl media
night we learned some stuff met some new
friends I had one of the best times of
my life I'm sorry I'm sorry